[Musica]
[Applauso]
come percepiamo i dati lo siete mai
chiesto che percezione ne abbiamo se lo
chiedete a me io vi dico che noi esseri
umani abbiamo delle vere e proprie
emozioni dei sentimenti quasi per i dati
c'è chi ne ha paura c'è chi ne è un po
spaventato c'è chi è interessato
io personalmente ne sono affascinato
li trovo fantastici trovo che si possono
fare veramente un sacco di cose come i
dati oggi sono qui per far vedere un po
la mia visione di come i dati possano
cambiare il mondo di come già lo stiano
facendo e di quello che appunto si può
fare con loro
se ci pensate i dati interpretano
perfettamente quello che è il tema del
cambiamento o del cambiamento è stato
detto
questi dati possono fare di tutto
trent'anni fa non erano minimamente
considerati mentre oggi se non enorme
fonte di informazione di ricchezza
come sapete esistono dati di tutti i
tipi dati pubblici dati privati da
citati sociologici fisici finanziari
metereologici di ogni genere
esiste persino una figura lavorativa che
si occupa specificatamente dei dati che
è stata creata di recente che è il data
scientist ed è un po grazie a un data
science che io sono qui oggi
quindi però questa è tutta un'altra
storia
ma che cosa sappiamo veramente sui dati
cioè che cosa sappiamo
perché ne siamo talmente circondati
talmente immersi che il rischio quello
di non capirli appieno non comprendere
che cosa possono fare per noi
ecco io penso che la chiave per capire
il mondo sia quella di porsi le giuste
domande
nello scrivere questo talk io mi sono
posto una valanga di domande e ne ha
selezionate alcune per voi che secondo
me ha senso porsi per capire meglio il
problema per capire meglio i dati
inizierei dalla più ovvia la più
semplice la più banale che io fino ad
ora ho dato totalmente per scontato
che cos'è un dato ci avete mai pensato
che cos'è
prendiamo per esempio la mia età io ho
29 anni
ora mi serve un po il vostro aiuto chi
pensa che 29 questo numero passi a un
dato per alzata di mano o siete timidi
non si vince non si perde niente
perfetto chi invece pensa che non lo sia
perfetto gli altri probabilmente si
astengono
la risposta è che dipende
dipende perché immaginate di essere in
giro per la città e vedere una
pubblicità di questo genere un enorme 29
scritto su un cartello un cartellone e
basta voi lo osservatelo guardate qual è
la prima cosa che vi viene da fare
è la prima cosa che viene da fare è
quella di osservare intorno a questo 29
vedere se c'è qualcosa qualche
informazione ulteriore che vi faccia
capire questo 29 che cosa si riferisce
se è un brand se è un oggetto se è
un'idea c'è un candidato politico
questa è proprio la chiave voi in quel
momento cercate un contesto
un dato infatti è un'informazione come
può essere essere questo 29 legato ad un
contesto che in questo caso sarei io
sarebbe la mia età il fatto che 29 è
un'età
ora se ci pensate bene da questo punto
di vista
qualsiasi cosa può diventare un dato
qualsiasi informazione se noi la
contestualizziamo nel modo corretto
diventa un dato
è questo uno dei motivi per cui
ultimamente si sente così tanto parlare
di questi big data intesi come grandi
quantità di dati questo perché noi ormai
siamo in grado di raccogliere salvare e
utilizzare un enorme quantità di dati
a questo punto la domanda che viene
spontanea diventa
quanti dati esistono visto che siamo in
grado di raccogliere così tanti quanti
ce ne sono
da una stima si è visto che nel 2018
la quantità di dati che eravamo riusciti
a raccogliere era di 18z byte
un numero che nel 2025 arriverà a
175 zettabyte
ora dalle vostre facce vedo che vi state
chiedendo ma che cos'è uno zettabyte
è chiaro noi siamo abituati a lavorare
con i megabyte gigabyte a volte i
terabyte quando scegliamo il nostro
telefono a nostro smartphone nel nostro
computer e il nostro tablet cosa diavolo
è un oggetto ha mai
detto in parole povere uno zettabyte
equivale a 1.000 miliardi di gigabyte
però anche così mille miliardi e un
numero troppo grande non riusciamo a
quantificarlo non ne abbiamo la
percezione giusta per cui fatemi fare
qualche esempio per voi
uno dei dati con cui abbiamo più a che
fare nelle nostre vite sono le
fotografie ormai fotografiamo ovunque
siamo competenti assessorati delle
fotografie fotografiamo con amici al
mare e spiaggia in vacanza a casa al
nostro cane il nostro gatto qualsiasi
cosa ormai la fotografia
ecco una fotografia occupa circa 3
megabyte più o meno
ora immaginiamo di prendere il nostro
smartphone e girare il mondo
a fotografare ogni singola persona sulla
faccia della terra ognuno dei 7 miliardi
e mezzo di esseri umani che vivono sulla
terra
e immaginiamo di ripetere questa
operazione
fino a riempire i nostri 175 zettabyte
ecco noi un'operazione di questo genere
la potremo ripetere per 8 milioni di
volte
8 milioni di voti 8 milioni è un numero
anche qui enorme sono 200 fotografie
ogni giorno per cento anni a ogni
singolo essere umano sulla faccia della
terra
un altro dei dati con cui abbiamo molto
a che fare sono i film vediamo tutti i
film sappiamo che durano un'ora due ore
tre ore quattro ore al massimo in casi
estremi
ecco immaginiamo ancora una volta di
voler girare un film che duri abbastanza
da riempire una volta salvato su un
numero enorme di blu ray per riempire i
nostri 175 z bike
ecco film del genere durerebbe un
miliardo e mezzo di anni
gli serve una vasca di pop corn
gigantesca per vedervelo tutto enorme
oppure un po più romanticamente pensiamo
a tutte le parole che siano mai state
dette dagli esseri umani dall'inizio
della nostra storia fino ad oggi
immaginiamo di prendere tutte queste
parole e salvare su un file di testo e
anche qui ripetere questa operazione
ancora e ancora fino a riempire i nostri
175 zettabyte
ecco noi potremo raccogliere per 35 mila
volte tutte le parole dette dall'essere
umano nella sua storia capite bene
quelli che si sta parlando veramente di
un'enorme quantità di dati
a questo punto la domanda è
successiva diciamo è da dove arrivano
questi dati
come li generiamo
ormai abbiamo dispositivi che generano
dati in ogni contesto ovunque ovunque
generiamo dati si è stimato che nel 2020
l'anno scorso
avevamo 200 miliardi di dispositivi in
grado di generare dati 200 miliardi sono
30 dispositivi per ogni essere umano
sulla terra
ovviamente non sono solo dispositivi
personali come smartphone e tablet città
cento sono anche mouse stampanti sono
dispositivi hi ottine nelle industrie
sono dati dispositivi di ogni genere
anche nei nostri lavatrici ormai
generano dei lati si collegano allo
smartphone e possiamo generare dati
anche così
nel 2025 quando avremo questi 175 di cui
parlavo prima
noi saremo in grado di generare 05 z
byte di dati ogni giorno e questo dato è
destinato a crescere a crescere e
diventare sempre più grande
ora adesso che sapete che cos'è un dato
quanti ce ne sono da dove vengono
l'ultima domanda a che cosa servono cioè
con che scopo vengono raccolti dati
becco molto spesso noi abbiamo a che
fare con i dati come dicevo quando
portiamo foto quando mandiamo dei
messaggi scriviamo un'e mail
la nostra matrice eccetera eccetera
eccetera
forse però il dato il tipo di dati con
cui più abbiamo a che fare che a volte
ci disturba molto
sono i dati utilizzati per il marketing
a tutti voi sarà capitato di
andare a vedere un oggetto vederlo su
internet e di lì poi vedessero
riproposto su ogni pagina che si va a
visitare di lì in poi questo meccanismo
chiamato re target che è molto comune
molto utilizzato è uno dei modi con cui
i dati personali degli utenti vengono
utilizzate di più
ed è forse quello che un po ci
infastidisce di più parlando con amici e
parenti mi sono reso conto che il
sentimento questa volta che viene fuori
di più è quello di essere spiato mi
ispiro perché ci immaginiamo lì una
persona dietro il computer che dica
guardiano statica a io lo sapevo che
assiste fa niente l'essere gli articoli
per il giardinaggio
ovviamente non è così
i nostri dati vengono raccolti insieme a
quelli di migliaia di altri utenti e
utilizzati in maniera aggregata
per creare modelli per creare
statistiche eccetera eccetera eccetera
ciò non toglie però che questo
sentimento di riva gae anche senso che
noi ce l'abbiamo
oggi però volevo far vedere un modo che
si chiamerà un'accezione molto più
positiva di utilizzare i dati
fino adesso vi ho parlato di una serie
di dati che noi raccogliamo perché
facciamo una certa azione attiva
scattiamo una foto andiamo a vedere una
pagina internet
mandiamo un messaggio eccetera eccetera
esistono però le didattiche noi
raccogliamo in maniera passiva rispetto
all'utente abbiamo tutti in tasca un
cellulare ormai diventato indispensabile
nostre vite
ecco l'interno del cellulare esistono
tutta una serie di sensori minuscoli che
sono in grado di raccogliere un enorme
quantità di informazioni riguardo a
quello che facciamo riesco a capire
quanti passi facciamo dove andiamo che
tipo di attività stiamo facendo
alcuni addirittura riescono a capire se
stiamo dormendo
ecco la cosa interessante che questi
sensori che sono così piccoli che
possiamo mettere ormai ovunque in
qualsiasi contesto così situazione di
possiamo utilizzare
io oggi sono salito su questo palco con
questo vistoso scarpone sicuramente
avrete notato perché molto ingombrante
questo è uno scarpone che viene
utilizzato in ambito medico con pazienti
diabetici affetti da ulcere plantari
la particolarità di questo scarpone è
che per essere efficace deve essere
indossato le assen dotato tutti i giorni
e con esso devono essere fatte
determinate attività come camminare e
stare sdraiati e stare seduti a seconda
della terapia che viene assegnata
è molto importante per un medico
assicurarsi che questo scarpone venga
indossato nel modo corretto
perché altrimenti le conseguenze sono
davvero nefaste e alcuni casi si ricorre
addirittura all'amputazione dell'arto
quando la malattia degenera
e potente quelli che è molto importante
per un medico assicurarsi del suo
paziente faccia le cose giuste
questo il motivo per cui noi abbiamo
ideato questo
questo è un minuscolo dispositivo è
grande come una moneta da due euro
praticamente che contiene i sensori
molto simili a quelli che voi avete sui
vostri smartphone e si applica
semplicemente qui in questo modo
ecco che ora lo scarpone cambia
completamente forma diventa un oggetto
completamente diverso diventa smart è in
grado di raccogliere di dati e a tramite
quei dati tramite un processamento dei
dati e grado di capire se il paziente il
nostro scarpone che attività ci fa
quando quando le fa come le fa e di dare
un feedback immediato allo smartphone
del paziente riguarda la sua terapia
riguarda quello che lui sta facendo gli
può dare dei consigli delle informazioni
utili
ma non solo perché grazie a un sistema
cloud che abbiamo creato tutto attorno
questi dati potranno essere mandati
direttamente a un medico che comodamente
da casa o dal suo studio potrà guardare
questi dati potrà osservare potrà vedere
immediatamente se il suo paziente ha
bisogno di aiuto o meno se sta facendo
le cose che deve fare se la terapia
viene seguita nel modo corretto
ovviamente un medico non a un singolo
paziente ne ha molti e infatti noi
grazie a un sistema di punteggio che
abbiamo ideato siamo in grado di
suggerire al medico quale paziente abbia
bisogno di un intervento immediato
perché non sta seguendo la terapia e
quale paziente invece potrà essere
lasciato in pace tranquillo perché sta
facendo ciò che deve fare perché la sua
terapia viene seguita nel modo corretto
questo però non è l'unico dei grandi
vantaggi di un sistema di questo genere
anche qui e ora mi serve un po della
vostra immaginazione pensate a quando
andate dal medico per una visita
normale tranquillissima la visita di
vista di controllo a un certo punto il
medico prendendo stetoscopio ve lo
appoggia sulla schiena e vi chiede fate
tre bei respiri profondi
ora non so voi ma io in quei tre respiri
ci metto tutto me stesso
cerco di far sì che siano il più
uniforme possibile più tranquilli
possibili più regolari possibili più
calmi e possibile
questo è un comportamento molto comune
chiamato effetto hawthorne e si sa
quando un paziente sa di essere
osservato sa che qualcuno lo sta
guardando sta guardando i suoi risultati
e cerca di apparire meglio di quello che
cerca di sembrare migliore in questo
modo però falsa il risultato dell'esame
falsa il dato
ecco con un sistema di questo genere
invece superato il primo momento per
abituarsi ad utilizzarlo perché punto
abbastanza ingombrante un paziente potrà
vivere la sua vita tranquillamente
utilizzando questo scarpone e noi
potremo raccogliere dei dati in tempo
reale
che ci diano delle informazioni
sull'effettivo efficacia di questo
scarpone sull'utilizzo di questo
scarpone potremo compiere degli studi
molto dettagliati ed è quello che stiamo
facendo su come questo scarpone
effettivamente guarisca il paziente e su
come migliorarlo
tutto questo sistema che io ora vi ho
descritto
è quello che noi chiamiamo aiomi che sta
per internet of me l'internet basato
sulle essere umano su di noi sulla
nostra persona da contrapporre al più
comune ai otite conosciamo credo quasi
tutti non lo so che è l'internet of
things l'internet delle cose degli
oggetti degli oggetti inanimati
questo può sembrare un piccolo
cambiamento ma è un enorme cambiamento
qui stiamo centrando la raccolta dei
dati per migliorare noi per migliorare
la nostra condizione per aiutare
pazienti per salvare vite per salvare
arti questo è un enorme cambiamento che
stiamo facendo
ecco con questo io spero di avergli
fatto capire che non tutti i dati
vengono per nuocere
grazie
[Applauso]